Musik Damen und Herren, herzlich willkommen, hier sind's wieder, Florentin, The Gag Machine, Will und Stefan, Gag Revolver, Tietze, weil er hat nur Platz für sechs Gags. Es klang in der Generalprobe aber noch wesentlich enthusiastischer, mein Lieber, du kannst nicht einfach dann die ganze amte Luft rausnehmen. Die Luft war super, die Luft war ganz toll, gefüllt, angereichert mit Gags, quasi übersättigt mit Gags, und dann musste Florentin seinen Tee noch fertig machen, dann ist die Luft einfach raus. Ja, ich brauche jetzt einfach immer einen Tee zur Aufnahme, das ist einfach jetzt, das gehört jetzt dazu. Wenn du jetzt nicht ablieferst, ne, du musst es abliefern, der Tee muss es jetzt gebracht haben, auf jeden Fall. Ich hatte eigentlich auch eine Anmoderation geplant, das ist ja toll, dass du mir das einfach so aus der Hand reißt, ne, ich wollte sagen, herzlich willkommen zu das Podcast-Ufo, zu Folge 22,5, wahrscheinlich mit demselben Thema wie der letzten Folge, weil Sie es nicht überlegt haben. 23,5, ja. Ja, 23,5. Und hier ist Stefan Titze, der Mann mit so viel Selbstbewusstsein wie ein Gemüsespieß auf dem Grill. So, das war meine Anmoderation. Hey, danke schön. Ja, die hast du in der Generalprobe auch schon gehört. Ach so, so meinst du, oder was? Nee, ich mein's eher negativ. Ich dachte eher negativ. Ich dachte, das ist wie, wenn du dir einen Grill vorstellst und da sind lauter saftige Steaks und Würstchen. Ich hab dir wie immer nicht zugehört. Ich hab dir wie immer nicht zugehört und dachte mir, ich hau mal einen, hey, Dankeschön raus, um so ein bisschen Selbstbewusstsein auszustrahlen. Das ist gut, so kann man Mobbing auch direkt. Wie ein Gemüsespieg im Vegetarier-Schrank. Nee, so kann man Mobbing auch direkt entgegenstürmen, indem man sich einfach bedanken, so danke, nur halbbem Ohr zuhören. Ja, dankeschön, okay, ciao. Eigentlich ideal. Das kann man echt gut. Also, ich muss mich entschuldigen für uns beide, wir hatten letzte Woche Internetprobleme. Wir wissen nicht genau, an wem es liegt. Ich habe eben einen Speedtest gemacht und hatte 776 Bits oder so pro Sekunde. Das ist nicht so viel. Also vielleicht lag es an mir, vielleicht ist irgendwas schiefgelaufen hier. Ja, finde ich interessant, dass du dich zuerst bei den Zuhörern entschuldigst und nicht, dass du die letzte Woche mich, glaube ich, viereinhalb Stunden lang am Stück fertig gemacht hast. Angeschrieben, ich habe mich angeschrieben. Wie kann man so dumm sein und seinen VPN-Server nicht aufmachen, wenn man aufnimmt? Wie kann man nur so dumm sein, seinen Browser offen zu lassen? Seine Impression von mir ist echt gut, gefällt mir sehr gut. Wie kann man nur, warst du schon jemals im Internet, wie kann man nur so dumm sein,
den Mail-Programm offen zu haben, wenn man einen Podcast aufnehmen will, ja? Das sind die 1 zu 1 Zitate von Stefan Titzel letzte Woche. Und jetzt, Entschuldigung, liebe Zuhörer, nee, entschuldige dich mal ordentlich bei dir, denn das ist nämlich das Thema der Folge, lege ich jetzt mal fest. Entschuldigung. Entschuldigung, ja? Es ist auch mal wichtig, doch, es ist auch mal wichtig, auf Fehler zurückzugucken und zu sagen, hey, da habe ich was falsch gemacht und einfach Entschuldigung zu sagen, einfach zu sagen sorry, ups, also es tut mir wirklich leid, dass ich letzte Woche dich drei Stunden am Stück angeschrien habe, weil ich dachte, dass du wegen, weil du das nebenbei, dachte ich, so ein grosses Internetrollenspiel spielst und deswegen die Folge nicht gut wurde, weil du Internet, wo du das gespielt hast und das war mein Fehler und ich entschuldige mich. Das ist wie bei Kindern, die man dazu zwingt, sich zu entschuldigen, wo man dann auch sagt, ja, jetzt gib ihm auch die Hand, gib ihm auch die Hand, so als wäre das dann, als wenn man die Hand gibt, dann hat man sich wirklich entschuldigt. Weil man auch merkt, dass es nicht den Effekt hat, den man wollte. Man zwingt ein Kind, sich dazu zu entschuldigen, merkt dann aber, das hat überhaupt keinen Effekt.
Und dann sagt man, ja, dann gib ihm halt nochmal dein Federmäppchen jetzt. So, damit man einfach irgendwas hat, damit irgendwas Objektives geschehen ist in der Welt. Ja genau, das ist wirklich interessant. Du hast ja letztens, lass uns mal ganz kurz über Gags reden, weil du hast ja letztens gesagt, als wir über Träume gesprochen haben, dass du von einem Gag geträumt hast, von dem besten Gag aller Zeiten, dann hast du dir dann aufgeschrieben in der Nacht, bist aufgewacht und hast gemerkt, dass es nur Schwachsinn war und der Gag überhaupt nicht lustig war. Jetzt habe ich letztens ein Sketch geträumt und wir schreiben ja gerade Sketche zusammen, also wir sind ja professionelle Frau-Kranaten. Also wir schreiben Sketche, ich weiß nicht, was du da bis jetzt geschrieben hast, das kann man, ob das man schon als Sketch bezeichnen kann, aber du hast auch geschrieben. Willst du dich nächste Folge wieder entschuldigen müssen? Willst du, dass sich das jetzt wiederholt? Entschuldigung. Auf jeden Fall habe ich einen Sketch geträumt und ich möchte jetzt einfach mal ganz kurz den dir vorsetzen als Experte, ob der wirklich gut ist oder nicht, weil ich fand den jetzt gar nicht so schlecht dafür, dass ich ihn geträumt habe, weil wie geil wäre das denn? Man hat irgendwie einen Beruf und träumt einfach ständig die Dinge und streift einfach nieder und sagt, ja gut, done, Arbeit getan für heute. Das ist wie, als wenn du irgendwie so ein Pakethaus arbeiten würdest und so ein Paketwahn oder so ein Logistikunternehmen und im Traum Pakete einräumen kannst, du morgens in die Firma kommst und es eingeräumt ist. Genau, ist alles schon fertig, du warst die Nacht hier. Du warst zwar nicht ansprechbar, aber du warst die ganze Nacht trainieren. Das ist etwa vergleichbar oder nicht? Also wenn man das unter Job, was eben traum machbar ist, total geil. Und deswegen liegt jetzt genau alles, meine grosse Hoffnung liegt jetzt an der Qualität dieses Sketches. Wenn der wirklich gut ist, dann habe ich, glaube ich, meinen Traumberuf gefunden. Dann kann ich meinen Beruf vollständig schlafend liegend machen. Und zwar, es ist, sage ich mal, jetzt nicht der innovativste Sketch, weil es ist die klassische Methode von, wir nehmen etwas Bekanntes und fügen es auf eine andere Situation ein. Und du kennst ja diese Situation nach dem Fussballspiel, wenn die Fussballer interviewt werden, so direkt nach dem Spiel. So, ja, hier Minute 180 war ja total scheiße, da kam dann irgendwie die blaue Karte und dann bin ich irgendwie ins Abseits gelaufen und dann habe ich ihn zweimal irgendwie in den Korb geworfen und das hätte eigentlich gar nicht sein dürfen. Und dann ganz laut Mau-Mau vergessen zu rufen. Genau, so habe ich aus Versehen zum Hotdog-Verkäufer gepasst und so, das lief alles nicht optimal. So, diese Interviews kennst du ja, ne? Und jetzt dachte ich mir, habe ich geträumt, man überträgt diese Situation auf ein klassisches Konzert, dass nach dem Konzert so die Musiker alle nochmal zurückgehen in die Dusche und interviewt werden und so, ja was der was der Dirigent da bei Minute dreissig gemacht hat im Takt achtundzwanzig, das ist ja wohl eine Riesensauerei, oder? Also das ist der Sketch.
Auch eine Rockband oder so. So eine Rockband, die so eine Metalband, die die ganze Zeit die krasseste Show abfeiert und dann am Ende nochmal müssen sie dann so einen Field Reporter, der fragt, ja gut, bei Sekunde fünfhundertdreiundzwanzig haben Sie jetzt nicht genau in Takt sieben das Fiss gespielt. Was war da los? Genau, ja, da haben Sie langhaarige Menschen an Antworten. Also, findest du gut oder nicht? Ist okay. Findest du es besser als das, was ich sonst so schreibe, im Wachenzustand? Ja, also glaube ich, du solltest jetzt deinen Job in Zukunft im Ligen im Schlaf und ausführen am besten. Okay, dankeschön. Du bist jetzt inception-mäßig an so eine Schlafmaschine angeschlossen und wir können dann deine Träume anzapfen. Und das nehmen wir dann, das quasi dann bist du dann als Florentin Wilder, der Autor. Weiß man jetzt nicht, ob das ein Kompliment ist oder nicht, ob ich will, dass mein Schlaf ich besser ist als ich. Es ist definitiv eine Bereidigung, es ist definitiv eine Bereidigung, das kann ich dir jetzt nicht. Gut, danke. Es so, wie wenn jemand sagt, wenn ich letztens jemand getroffen habe und gesagt habe, ach Mensch, du bist ja gar nicht so fett, wie ich dachte. Wo man auch kurz nachdenken, also ich bin schon fett, aber du dachtest, ich sei noch fetter. Du dachtest die ganze Zeit, ich sei noch fetter. Von daher weiss ich nicht. Wir haben ja letztes Mal über Nostalgie gesprochen, ne? Und ich habe mal was mitgebracht.
Also ich habe jetzt heute mal hier was mitgebracht, und zwar... Das Fundstück der Woche, Woche!
Pass auf, pass auf.
Ich mache es mal an und mal gucken, ob jemand was erkennt.
Also ich habe was mitgebracht und ich mache es jetzt an.
Ah!
Okay, ist es noch?
Man erkennt es schon, pass auf. Ist das nicht toll? Das ist grossartig. Passt das nicht so gross, ist die Nostalgie gerade? Lass uns im Hintergrund noch ein bisschen weiter laufen. Ich halte es noch hier dran. Geil. Und weißt du, was geil ist? Ich habe gerade letzte Woche mir die rote Edition auf Amazon bestellt. Weil meine Freundin und ich fahren dieses Jahr wieder zum Campen an irgendeinen See eine Woche lang.
Und wir haben es zur Tradition gemacht, dass wir jedes Jahr einmal Pokémon durchzocken. Also jeder für sich. Und ich habe allerdings meine Edition verloren im Umzug und mit der ganzen Berlin-Sache und so. Und deswegen habe ich das letzte Woche noch bestellt. Aber ich frage mich auch, also komponiert man das dann, also komponieren die das mit
einem richtigen? Aber ich frage mich auch, also komponiert man das dann, also komponieren die das mit
einem richtigen, mit unterschiedlichen Instrumenten oder komponieren das direkt auf so eine 8-Bit-Maschine?
Ich glaube, die komponieren das direkt 8-Bit, ja. Es gab ja sogar hier dieses Super Mario,
nee, Doktor Mario oder so, da konnte man auf dem Gameboy dann auch selber Musik machen,
selber 8-Bit-Musik, ja, das war dann tatsächlich ganz geil. Ich kann mal kurz ins Pokécenter reingehen. Das ist schon grossartig, ne? Herrlich. Das war auch immer nervig, wenn man einmal zu oft aufs A gedruckt hat und dann nochmal die Pokémon heilen musste. Was für mich, ich war immer schon ein sehr pragmatischer Mensch, immer schon scheiße war, weil ich dachte mir, komm, die sind schon heile, jetzt müsst ihr nicht nochmal irgendwie eure Geräte da anschmeißen. Das ist eine wahnsinnige Energieverschwendung. Wenn die Frau jetzt nochmal dieses Ding abfeuert, was im Hintergrund die ganze Zeit so leuchtet, da ist ja im Hintergrund so ein Fenster, was die ganze Zeit so leuchtet, als wäre da irgendwie so Riesenelektroden, so Tesla-Spulen oder so, angeschlossen. Kurz unter Starkstrom gesetzt. Es gibt so unfassbar komische Dinge verlaufen da hinten ab. Und das macht ihr jetzt bitte nicht noch mal, weil die sind ja schon geheilt. Also, warum uns noch mal? Ach so, nicht aus Zeitsparen, sondern aus Schutzreflex, dass du sagst. Ich dachte mir, das ist eine wahnsinnige Energieverschwendung. Du denkst, auch doppelt heilen ist dann wieder schlecht. Also Plus und Plus ergibt Minus. Plus und Plus ist immer Minus, ja. Merkt euch das, genau. Aber ich finde, ja, also man denkt, geil, ich hätte gerne wieder so einen Gameboy, aber es ist nicht so geil wie damals eigentlich, oder? Ich denke, das ist das Fazit, das wir zu Nostalgie ziehen können. Es ist halt, die Erinnerung ist besser als die tatsächliche Sache. Das ist genauso wie Sex. Also ich weiß nicht. Das ist genauso wie Sex.
Also ich weiß nicht.
Das ist genauso wie, sag jetzt was, ich schneide dann die Pause weg.
Sag mal was Lustiges jetzt.
Komm.
Ich gebe dir jetzt die Zeit.
Das war eine unglaublich natürliche und angenehme Gesprächsatmosphäre.
Nee, sag jetzt mal was Lustiges.
Die Pause schneide ich weg.
Mein Teil schneide ich weg. Sag du jetzt mal was Lustiges.
Ja, komm.
Der Gedanke daran ist besser als die Sache selbst, genauso wie, ach mein Gott, da kann man nichts Lustiges sagen, wenn euch da draußen was lustiges dazu einfällt, Mr. Deine Replier sind lustiger als du selbst, ja, kannst du jetzt mal die Idee aber ficken hier. Es ist wirklich so, wenn mittlerweile deine Replier, deine, deine, deine, das ist aber nicht so, nein, nein, nein. Leute, die bei denen mittlerweile auch Tweets antworten, sind lustiger als du selbst. Damit musst du dich abfinden. Das ist der Moment... Das bringt mich jetzt in eine ganz unangenehme Situation. Das ist der Moment, wo du an deinem Zenit der Karriere angekommen bist. Nein, nein, nein. Twitter ist Freestyle, Twitter ist Improvisation. Man wirft was rein, man kriegt was zurück. Man kann nicht sagen, da ist jetzt einer besser als der andere. Du wirst die Feedline rein und die Punchline kommt da von deinen Followern zurück. Das ist eine sehr gute Taktik. Weiß ich nicht. Nein, nein, nein, das stimmt ja nicht. Du bist ein sehr lustiger Typ, auch privat. Ja, das ist ein sehr lustiger Typ. Ich haue jetzt mal einen Tweet raus. Nein, was ich aber kurz noch sagen wollte. Es ist wirklich so. Also es ist nicht so geil. Dieser Gameboy ist nicht so geil, wenn man ihn in der Hand hat. Also das ist wirklich, der ist dick, der ist schwer, das Akku hält nicht lang, der Akku hält nicht lang, was soll man, wie das heißt, keine Ahnung, wie man das nennt.
Und dann ist die Beleuchtung auch nicht so geil, wenn man in der Sonne steht, sieht man gar nichts mehr, dann ist es, die Grafik ist auch nicht wirklich gut. Aber ich bin enttäuscht eigentlich. Also mit normalen Maßstäben kann man natürlich nicht weit kommen. Es ist natürlich immer dieses Gefühl, was in der Hand zu haben, was man damals schon in der Hand hatte. Das ist, glaube ich, das, was Nostralgie ausmacht. Ja, das ist auch, wenn man auf Spotify mal wieder über so eine Nineties-Playlist stolpert und sich denkt, oh geil, Saturday Night, Cotton Eye Joe, wie geil ist das, dann macht man die an und einfach nach fünf Minuten hat man so viel alles kaputt gemacht in seinem Raum, weil es einfach wahnsinnig wird. Man hört auch nicht jedes Lied zu Ende, also nur die ersten zehn Sekunden sind geil, so die Erinnerungen... Saturday Night, und das war's schon, das reicht, danke. Das ist wie Beethoven's Stück, hatten wir so auch schon. Genau, Jamba hat's da eigentlich schon richtig gemacht. Ich habe mir tatsächlich damals, also wir reden uns über damals, ich habe mir im Jamba-Spar-Abo einmal einen Klingelton runtergeladen, weil ich ihn haben wollte, von meinem Lieblingssong damals. Crazy Frog. Nee, es war mein damaliger Lieblingssong Hey Ja von Outcast und ich hatte damals aber kein gutes Handy,
genau, ich hatte damals kein gutes Handy, sondern nur irgendwie so monoton statt Polyphon oder Xylophon.
Ich hatte nur monoton, das heißt, das Lied war dann wirklich der Klingelton, wirklich
So in etwa war dieser fucking Klingelton, wo ich mir echt dachte, wow, dafür habe ich jetzt ein Mark-90-Abo pro Monat abgeschlossen, um das teilzuhaben. Dann habe ich mir aber noch Is It Corsair Cool von Musti runtergeladen und dann war alles wieder in Ordnung. Das ist der fucking coolste Song der Welt. Das stimmt wirklich, das stimmt wirklich. Aber auch nur für zehn Sekunden danach haben wir auch keinen Bock mehr auf das Lied. Ja. Naja. Aber so ein bisschen ist er ja mit diesem neuen Jurassic Park Film. Da ist es ja auch so ein bisschen so, Dinosaurier, Dinosaurier, man braucht nur genug Entusiasmus. Du musst aufpassen, dass sie dich nicht fressen. Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen damit, in den ersten zehn Sekunden von dem Film hat man so, hat man, denkt man, ja, cool, also das ist schon ganz geil, so ein Park mit Dinosauriern. Und das ist ja auch wie damals und so, diese Momente zwischendurch, wo man denkt, geil, das war früher schon ein echt guter Film. Aber irgendwie reicht es auch nicht mehr für einen Film, dass nur man diese Nostalgiemomente so anschneidet. Nee, absolut. Und ich meine, das ist ja auch eine Geldmacherscheibenmaschinerie. Man hält uns ja an der Nostalgie fest, wir bringen jetzt einen neuen Film rein, jetzt kommt ein neuer Snoopy-Film, wo man natürlich auch sagt, geil Snoopy, aber es ist in diesem Jahr auch extrem. Also Mad Max knüpft an was Früheres an, dann kommt noch ein neuer Avengers raus, dann kommt noch ein Batman vs. Superman raus, dann kommt Jurassic Park raus, Star Wars raus. Ja, und meine ganzen Filmideen verrotten in der Schublade und niemand will sie. Slinky der Film, hallo, was ist für eine geile Idee? Wollen wir mal unsere Top 5, Top 4 Filmideen raushauen? Ja, klar. Okay, warte mal. Dann fange ich gleich mal mit Platz, weil da müssen wir jetzt erst mal 20 Minuten schreiben oder? Entschuldigung, kurz. Wir machen jetzt kurz eine 20-minütige Pause. Warte, lass uns wirklich mal eine kurze Pause machen, schnell es dann raus.
Ja, okay, ab jetzt.
Okay, mir fällt überhaupt nichts ein.
Ja, lassen wir das lieber, oder?
Okay, lassen wir das.
So, wir sind wieder da, uns ist nichts eingefallen.
Überhaupt nichts, gar nichts.
Antiklimatischste Punkt überhaupt. Aber wir brauchen trotzdem so einen Trenner mit so einer spannungsaufbauenden Musik,
die jetzt die Erwartungen strapaziert und dann kommen wir, indem wir sagen, hier sind wir wieder, haben keine Idee gehabt und dann kommt der Trenner wieder, okay? Hast du diese Ansprache von Jon Stewart gesehen, zu diesem Angriff auf diese Kirche in dieser schwarzen Gemeinde, wo er in Amerika gerade wieder Schwarz vs. Weiss hochkocht und Jon Stewart hat sich hingesetzt und gesagt, ja, mein Job ist es, sich die aktuellen Sachen anzuschauen und drüber Witze zu machen, den habe ich heute nicht gemacht. Ich habe mir heute keine Witze ausgedacht und alle lachen, haha, was für ein toller Gag und so. Nee, ganz im Ernst, ich habe heute keinen einzigen Gag dabei und alle haha lachen, aber der zieht es wirklich durch. Der macht einen fünfminütigen Monolog und sagt halt wirklich einfach ernst, was in Amerika irgendwie schiefläuft und was das Problem ist. Und die Leute am Anfang lachen noch so an manchen Stellen, weil sie denken, das sei nur ein Scherz, aber das ist kein Scherz, das ist wirklich,
er hat einfach keinen einzigen Witz dabei, aber es ist
total krass, das geht total
nah und es ist echt krass, die immer zu sehen und zu
sagen, so, nee, ich mache heute keine Gags, das liegt mir echt am
Herzen, schaut euch an, John Stewart. Glaubst du, wir können das auch?
Oh ja, das ist ja
eine gute Idee. Wir können, wir können jetzt
mal uns gegenseitig die ernstmöglichste
Frage stellen. Jeder muss
eine noch ernstere Frage dem anderen zurückstellen.
Wir stellen ja immer so lustige Fragen wie
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Slinky und Kartoffelbrei?
Eine klassische Frage.
Aber stellen wir uns mal eine richtig ernste Frage.
Und dann müssen wir auch ernst beantworten,
oder müssen wir die nicht ernst beantworten,
sondern auch in unserem Kultus?
Wenn sie ernst genug ist, können wir sie schon beantworten.
Also du fängst an. Ernste Frage.
Stell mal eine ernste Frage.
Was war der erste Familienmitglied, was bei dir gestorben ist?
Okay, ich konntere mit, bist du glücklich?
Kannst du Liebe empfinden?
Glaubst du, man kann alleine wirklich glücklich werden?
Ist die Frisur dein Ernst?
Okay, da muss ich abbrechen. Ich bin jetzt gerade so emotional geworden.
Ich glaube, wir können das nicht so gut. Ich glaube, wir können nicht so gut ernste Fragen stellen. Wir sind eher so die unernsten Leute. Wir sind uns schon ein bisschen nahe gegangen, ehrlich gesagt.
Können wir vielleicht kurz eine Pause machen?
Können wir vielleicht nochmal eine fünfminütige Pause machen?
Warte mal.
Nur weil die Folge kürzer ist, heißt das nicht, dass wir ständig Pausen machen dürfen, ne?
Ich muss noch kurz was machen, damit wir wieder, wir müssen wieder hochkommen. Warte mal, ganz kurz, ganz kurz, ganz kurz, ganz kurz, ganz kurz, da, ich bin wieder zehn Jahre alt, da, da, da, da, da, hast du die Musik auch immer extra angelassen, auch bei jedem Event, irgendwie, wenn du im Restaurant warst, im Feinen, mit den Verwandten, immer schön die Musik auf, damit es jeden nervt am Tisch und damit jeder hört, was du spielst. Klar, natürlich. Es ist schon toll. Auch die Musik ist echt toll. Also da hat es wirklich Mühe gegeben. So, ich bin ja gut drauf. Apropos Musik, wir wollten noch mal eine Folge zu Musik machen, ne? Ja, wir wollten mal eine Folge nur singend bestreiten, also quasi eine Musical-Folge, wo wir alles, was wir sagen, singen. Aber auch mal Thema Musik. Ich habe letztens ein Lied gehört, das mir irgendwie in Erinnerung geblieben ist, und zwar habe ich den kompletten Soprano-Soundtrack gehört. Ganz kurz mal eben, ist heute eine Folge, wo wir quasi, ist das die zweite Folge der Woche, wo wir also auch eine Dreiviertelstunde lang reden müssen? Ja, das ist Express. Oder ist es die, ach so, also können wir schneller reden. Naja, was heißt eine Dreiviertelunde? Lass uns eine halbe Stunde machen oder sowas. Ja, okay, alles klar. Weil das ist ja unfair, wenn wir statt einer Stunde zweimal 45 Minuten machen, dann haben wir uns in der Hals schon erschienen. Finde ich auch voll unfair. Das ist jemand, das von uns verlangt. Finde ich auch irgendwie ein bisschen dreist. Aber es ist wirklich so, dass wenn Leute was kostenlos bekommen, dass sie dann relativ schnell dreist werden, oder? Sie wollen einfach mehr. Auch so Drohungen wie ja, wenn man sich auf Podcast-Uvo verlässt, braucht man keine Feinde mehr und so. Solche Nachrichten. Wow, unfassbar schlagfertigen Hörer. Ja, und auch unsere unfassbar schlagfertigen Antworten. Und nichts. Unfassbar schlagfertigen Moderatoren, ja. Einfach nichts. Okay, hast du Sopranos geguckt? Ich habe den Soundtrack von Sopranos, das ist ja auch tatsächlich Nostalgie ein bisschen. Sopranos, die beste Serie aller Zeiten tatsächlich und besticht natürlich auch mit ihrer genialen Musikauswahl. Habt ihr gesehen? Ja, dann halt nicht. Schau dir was anderes an. Herzlich willkommen zu den besten Gesprächspartnern aller Zeiten. Und zwar über sechs Staffeln. Natürlich immer mit einer sehr guten Musikauswahl. Kön könnt ihr mal gucken bei Spotify, Sopranos Musik. Und da gibt es ein Lied und das führt eine Metapher an und es ist ein Liebeslied, singt eine Frau zu einem Mann. Ich hasse Frauen. Sie führt eine Metapher an, ja ich auch, sie führt eine Metapher an, wie sie sich diese Liebesbeziehung vorstellt. Und ich finde diese Metapher sehr eingängig und sehr berührend tatsächlich. Und zwar singt sie You'll be the Captain, ja, also du bist der Kapitän, also okay, ergibt absolut Sinn im künstlerischen Rahmen, sie will einen Mann, der bestimmt ist, der sie irgendwo hinführt, durch Leben führt, der Kapitän ist ja ein bisschen abenteuerlustig, der sie nicht gegen einen Eisberg rasen lässt, das Leben gegen einen Eisberg rasen lässt und sie krepieren lässt einen furchtbaren Tod. Genau, aber auf der anderen Seite auch ein bisschen abenteuerlustig.
Ein Kapitän ist ja, sage ich mal, jemand, der irgendwie das Weite sucht, das grosse Meer, die Unendlichkeit, den Horizont.
Ja, aber auf stürmischen See klarkommt, aber auch auf der flachen See. Ja, genau, der auf dem Horizont zu Hause ist, der die Frau auch mal in den Wind nimmt.
Der aber auch den Wind braucht, um nach vorne zu kommen.
Genau, der aber auch das Ruder.
Der eine raue See braucht, um ein guter Segler zu werden. Der aber auch einen Rud braucht, um nach vorne zu kommen. Genau, der aber auch das Ruder.
Der eine raue See braucht, um ein guter Segler zu werden.
Der aber auch einen Ruder in der Hand hat.
Und mit dem Ruder das Schiff steuern.
Der aber auch ein Steuermann ist.
Ja, aber der auch Segel hat.
Oder auch mit einem Bugstrahlruder sehr akkurat in den Hafen einfahren kann.
Ja, der aber auch eine Mannschaft hat.
Er macht es nicht alleine.
Der aber auch in der Kombüse, sagen wir mal, ein gutes, deftiges Gericht zaubern kann. Ja, natürlich, der aber auch unter Deck, sag ich mal, ordentlich, auch mal einen, ne, oder? Der aber auch mal den Mast hochklettern kann, um zu gucken, oh, wo ist denn Land in Sicht? Natürlich, der aber auch mal an Land geht, der nicht immer nur auf seinem Schiff bleibt, sondern auch mal an Land geht und sagt hier, was ist denn mit dem Land los? Der aber auch von Bug bis Heck schon was auf dem Kasten hat. Absolut, der auch mal auf der Planke steht. Der auch mal durchs Bullau geschaut. Der auch mal, der auch mal ein paar Knoten hat. Der auch mal den Anker lichten kann. Der auch mal jemanden Kiel holen kann, der mal sagt, wo es lang geht, wenn es hart wird. Der auch mal durchs Fernrohr schaut und guckt, ja, was ist denn da in der Ferne vielleicht. Der auch mal eine Karte lesen kann, der den Überblick hat, den Plan hat. Der auch mal vielleicht den Kompass in der Hand hat, um zu gucken, wo geht es denn hier hin, durch welche Meerenge können wir denn dieses Mal unser Schiff steuern. Der sich auch mit den Sternen auskennt, der nach oben gucken kann, der die Natur lesen kann, der weiss, wo es lang geht. Der auch mal das Echolot rausholen kann, um zu gucken, wie tief ist es denn eigentlich. Der auch mal vielleicht gar nicht so wichtig ist, weil es auf modernen Schiffen vielleicht den Kapitän gar nicht mehr in der Rolle gibt, ja, der mal abgeschafft werden kann, traditionell, romantisch, ja, auf eine alte Zeit hinweisen. Der auch mal den Animateur spielen kann und mit seiner tollen Uniform auf Deck gehen kann und mit den alten Ommers, die von ihren Enkeln eine Kreuzfahrt geschenkt bekommen haben, um die mal loszuwerden. Jemand, der vielleicht mal auch in Rente geht, der nicht immer nur Kapitän ist, der auch mal sagt, nee, das war's für mich, war heu! Der auch mal eine Nebenrolle auf dem Traumschiff spielt, vielleicht. Absolut, der vielleicht gar kein Kapitän ist, sondern vielleicht nur der Hausmeister, der gesagt hat, oh, zehnjähriger Florentin, du willst mit dem Kapitän sprechen, das bin ich, ja, vielleicht auch mal so jemand. Wir mussten diese Folge an dieser Stelle unterbrechen, da Florentin und Stefan das Ganze noch zehn Minuten weitergemacht haben. Wir geben die Folge jetzt wieder. Auf jeden Fall, das ist der Kapitän, ja, man hat ein Bild vor Augen, sie singt, du bist der Kapitän. So, jetzt, man denkt mal diese Metapher weiter, ja, wenn der Mann der Kapitän ist, was ist dann die Frau, ja, also was könnte sie singen? Also du bist jetzt Autor, diese Künstlerin kommt zu dir und sagt, ich habe da so eine Idee für ein Lied, und zwar, ich möchte singen You'll be the captain, I'll be Dein erster Mat. Naja, aber das ist ja eher so eine hierarchische Situation, ne? Man möchte ja nicht jetzt irgendwie den Mann untergeordnet sein. Früher wollten die Männer ja gar keine Frauen auf den Schiffen haben, weil die dachten, man bringt Unglück. Genau, diese alte Seemannsweisheit. War das wirklich so oder war das nur so eine Ausrede? Nee, Frauen bringen echt Unglück. Das merkt man ja auch im echten Leben. Aber nur auf Schiffen generell, oder? Also das ist schon ein bisschen blöd. Ja, deswegen sind Kreuzfahrtschiffe ja auch immer eher männlich. Nee, aber was wäre deine Idee? Also wenn du jetzt einen Liebesbrief schreiben müsstest und du würdest schreiben, du bist der Kapitän und ich bin ein blinder Passagier, der dich auf deiner Reise begleitet, wo auch immer du hinfährst, ich werde dabei sein, werde mich aber verstecken. Aber blinder Passagier spricht jetzt nicht unbedingt für dein Selbstbewusstsein. Wenn du sagst, oh, blinder Passagier finde ich sogar gar nicht so schlecht, im Sinne von, es ist sogar verboten, unsere Verbindung ist sogar verboten. Ja, genau. Nur du weißt, dass ich an Bord bin. Ich bin immer an Bord, egal was du machst. Auch dieses blinde Vertrauen, dass man ja als blinder Passagier hat, null Einfluss auf die Route. Du weißt ja keine Ahnung, wo es hingeht mit dem Schiff. Vielleicht bist du nächsten Tag in Timbuktu. Und es ist ja auch egal, wo es hingeht. Hauptsache, du bist auf dem Schiff, Hauptsache, du bist bei dem Kapitän. Wo das Schiff hinfährt, ist dir gar nicht so wichtig. Dir geht es darum, dass du mit dem Kapitän auf einem Schiff bist. Ja, das wäre mein Angebot. Das ist eine schöne Metapher. Ich löse mal auf, der Songtext lautet folgendermassen, You'll be the captain, I'll be no one. Ich bin niemand. Und als ich das das erste Mal gehört habe, dachte ich mir auch so, das ist eine seltsame Metapher. Du bist der Kapitän und ich bin niemand. Und ich dachte, da könnte man jedes beliebige Wort für Kapitän einsetzen, es hätte den gleichen Effekt. Ich hätte jetzt an deiner Stelle so die Angst, deshalb hätte ich auch diese Geschichte nicht erzählt, dass da irgendwas hinter steckt, was wir gerade nicht verstehen. Das kann gut sein. Das kann echt sein, so niemand, hier die Reise des Odysseus, da war niemand ja auch eine Figur, das war dieser Zyklop, und vor dem man sich reten wollte, hat man niemand genannt, genau. Und ich weiß nicht, vielleicht haben wir da irgendwas in der Sage nicht verstanden, oder die kennen das einfach nicht. Nein, aber es ist kein so altes Lied, ich glaube, es ist nicht so gemeint. Aber mir hat die Metapher einfach so schön gefallen. Erstens erniedrigt sich die Frau vollständig, sagt, du bist der Kapitän, ja, der Höchste, und ich bin nicht irgendwie dein Schiff oder der Wind in deinen Segeln, sondern ich bin niemand, ich bin nicht mal anwesend. Aber auch so ein bisschen arrogant, nur zu behaupten, ja, ich bin zwar niemand, aber immer noch gut genug für dich. Immer noch gut genug für dich, ja, oder vielleicht nicht, vielleicht besingt sie ja auch, dass sie sozusagen keine Chance hat bei ihm. Aber ich finde das geil, ich meine, die Metapher hätte genau denselben Effekt, wenn man sagen würde, du bist eine Tomate und ich bin niemand. Das hat genau denselben Effekt, weil das ist wie durch Nullteilen. Vielleicht hast du eine Wortreinfolge, die Frauen total gut finden, also wenn du von einer Frau gehst und sagst, hör mal, ich bin der Captain, du bist ein Niemand, dass sie dann voll auf dich abfahren und denken so, wow, das ist das Schönste, was ich jemals gehört habe und für Frauen klingt das wahnsinnig toll, aber so Männer haben einfach so das Gefühl, was ist das für eine Metapher, das macht ja keinen Sinn. Das ist eine seltsame Metapher, weil, also warum denn niemand, das ist wirklich das letzte. Ich glaube auch, dass in allen Frauen so ein Chip eingepflanzt ist und wenn man eine bestimmte Wortreinfolge sagt, dass sie dann irgendwie anders machen. Das habe ich auch mal auf einer Website gelesen. Ich hatte mal so eine Mail bekommen, wo man sagt, mit diesen Techniken kriegen sie jede Frau rum, sie müssen nur die Sachen machen. Ja, und anders als du lese ich diese Mails und veranschaue sie für unsere Hörer. Ich habe nur keine Geld gezahlt. Ja, was muss man denn machen, um eine Frau rumzukriegen? Ja, habe ich nicht ganz gelesen. Jetzt mal einfach Butter bei die Fische. Wenn man jetzt gerade kein Kapitän ist und die Angebetete niemand ist, was also mir schon oft passiert ist oder halt nicht, weiß ich auch nicht. Das ist auch geil, wenn so eine Ballade einfach in die komplett falsche Richtung geht. So, du bist mein Kapitän und ich bin niemand und dann wird der Song plötzlich von so einer romantischen Ballade in so einer Emo, emotional Nummer, so wie eine Selbstmitleid versinkende Frau, die plötzlich einfach anzwingt zu schreien, so hysterisch das Lied endet einfach. Das Lied komplett irgendwie ab einer Minute dreissig komplett in eine andere Richtung einschlägt. Ich finde es so gut, dass man so eine Welt der Metapher aufbaut und die dann sofort verlässt. So sagt so, hey, du bist beim Schach die Dame und ich bin Platon. Aber das ist auch so eine Frage, die ich mir stelle. Früher wurden ja Briefe, also erstmal war teures Briefpapier, teures Briefpapier war teuer. Leder, ja, Kuhhaut, man musste eine ganze Kuh schicken. Ja, und deswegen hat er mit der Hand geschrieben und man konnte es ja nicht so schnell wieder wegmachen. Tintenkeller ist ja auch eine Erfindung des späteren Jahres. Und das heißt, Wörter, die erstmal standen, die konnte man dann nicht ändern. Und wenn man so eine Metapher anfangen wollte wie, du bist mein Kapitän, fuck, mir fällt kein anderes Pendant als so ein. Ich bin niemand, da nehme ich halt niemanden, weil noch ein Rhein mir dazu einfällt oder so. Dann nimmt man das, glaube ich. Wann fing das denn an, dass man das löschen konnte, was man hingeschrieben hat? Das ist ein ganz interessanter Prozess. Wer war der erste Mensch, der etwas gelöscht hat, was aus seinem Papier steht? Nein, die Rubrik gibt es erst nächste Woche. Nee, gibt es keine Rubrik. Das ist die Express-Folge. Wir schneiden die Rubriken raus. Da gibt es ja den legendären Witz von einem Comedian, ich weiß gar nicht, wie er heisst, der an seinen Vater einen Brief schreiben wollte und schreiben wollte I really und hat sie verschrieben, er hat I rarely, also I selten, hat er geschrieben I rarely und dann hat hat er geschrieben, ja gut, was soll ich jetzt schreiben, und dann hat er geschrieben, I rarely drive Steamboats, einfach so völlig ohne Zusammenhang. Ja, mir geht's ganz gut, ich bin in Hawaii und ich fahre relativ selten Dampfschiffe, und naja, auf jeden Fall meine Frau und ich haben beschlossen, einfach so eingebaut. Ja, es war bei mir auch immer so, ich musste ja damals immer, meine Eltern haben mich immer gesagt, ja komm, ich treib mal Postkarten, nearten in die Verwandten oder so. Und ich war immer schon jemand, der sehr impulsiv geschrieben hat und immer so Satzanfänger im Kopf hatte. Und dann habe ich die auch schon aufgeschrieben. Und dann habe ich die halt zum ersten Mal mit Kulli geschrieben, weil wir nur einen Kulli da hatten im Urlaub irgendwie. Und dann habe ich immer Satzanfänger geschrieben und die irgendwie komplett ins Nichts geführt haben. Und dann musste ich aber irgendwie den Satz zu Ende bringen. Und dann habe ich das auch immer so gemacht, weil meine Postkarten waren immer mega weird. Ich freue mich wirklich, wenn ich selber Grossvater bin und einfach alle meine Enkel einfach dazu zwinge, mir Postkarten zu schreiben. Und dann kriege ich diese Postkarten und einfach unter Zwang so mit zittriger Hand, wo an der Handfläche noch irgendwie Poolwasser ist. Blut. Und genau meistens Kind wurde einfach aus dem Pool geholt und gesagt, du schreibst jetzt deine Karte an Grossvater. Dann schreibt man sie mit zittriger Hand irgendwas so, ja, die Pizza ist ja lecker hier in Italien. Die Tränen tropfen, wo der Postkarte zu sehen ist. Es gibt ja jetzt so ein Startup-Unternehmen, habe ich irgendwie gehört, da kann man quasi eine Postkarte direkt vom Handy verschicken. Also du kannst auf das Foto klicken, was du gemacht hast und das dann als Postkarte verschicken. Und dann kannst du als SMS quasi den Text reinschreiben. Was aber irgendwie das voll uncool macht, weil der Sinn der Postkarte besteht ja darin, dass man etwas handschriftlich draufschreibt. Das hast du ja nicht mehr. Ich würde als Postbote auch jede Postkarte lesen. Also gnadenlos. Machen die doch auch. Ja, ich schreibe teilweise auch liebe Grüße an den Postboten einfach nebenbei. Liebe Grüße an Harald. Gehört für mich mit dazu. Wenn dann plötzlich so eine Konversation draufsteht, wenn die Postboten dann auch antworten irgendwie. Und bevor der, der das dann erreichen soll, die Postkarte bekommt, ist dann mittlerweile schon so eine Konversation drauf, so ein Verlauf. Ja, das finde ich gut. So, ja, genau. You'll be the postman, I'll be no one. Das ist vielleicht auch ein ganz schönes Lied. Ich würde noch mehr Sinn ergeben, vielleicht. So unzustellbar von mir, so nach dem Motto die Post, die du mir schickst, ist unzustellbar und so. Ja. Wir sollten vielleicht mal zusammen Liebesbrief schreiben. Wir sollten mal Metaphern, wir sollten mal mehr Metaphern machen. Absolut, Metaphern sind eine feine Sache und wir können ja mal zusammen Liebes ja mal zusammen ... Metaphern sind wie Schlagzeuge. Eine gute Metapher ist wie das I von Pixar. Das habe ich auch nicht verstanden. Ich habe auch mal an einem Tweet gearbeitet, weil ja das I wird immer kaputt gemacht in dem Pixar Pixar Intro. Und da wollte ich schreiben irgendwie, ich war letztens im Krankenhaus und im Bett neben mir lag das I von Pixar. Aber dann dachte ich mir, das versteht niemand, also wirklich kein Mensch versteht diesen Gag. Jetzt habe ich ihn irgendwie noch Secondhand hier untergebracht. Naja, Entschuldigung, tut mir leid, ich schäme mich ein bisschen für den Gag. Ich bin dankbar, ich bin niemals dankbar, wenn du einen Gag unterbringst, wenn du es mal schaffst, dir einen Gag unterzubringen. Auch so nahtlos, so völlig ins... Ich habe neulich ein Video von dir gefunden, ein älteres von dir, ich weiß auch nicht warum, plötzlich ist es aufgeploppt bei mir und dann hast du was ausgesprochen, was ganz komisch ausgesprochen. Und ich würde mal kurz die ganze Community darauf aufmerksam machen wollen, dass du etwas ganz komisch aussprichst. Ich würde dich mal bitten, den Namen des Landes auszusprechen. Es ist das grösste asiatische Land. Indien. Nein, das andere. Russland. Asiatische Land. China. Okay, und jetzt sag mal hier zum Beispiel Chlor oder Natrium, was sind das? Chemikalien. Okay, ja, in diesem Sinne, wir haben... So, vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit. Vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit. Schreibt mal in die Kommentare, wie ihr das so fangst, was Chlor und Dina gerade gesagt haben. In diesem Sinne, nee, ich wollte mal kurz, wir müssen mal kurz, wir haben eine halbe Stunde geredet, also wir sind quasi durch eigentlich mit unserer Express-Folge. Aber ich wollte mal kurz, die Community hat ein paar Sachen gesagt, also zunächst einmal, danke an Mr. .txt für den Themenvorschlag, wir sollen mal Kickstarter-Projekte thematisieren. Danke dafür erstmal, danke für deinen Beitrag. Wir können ja ein eigenes Kickstarter-Projekt starten vielleicht und darüber reden und die Leute dazu bringen, da Geld zu spenden. Dann danke an denjenigen, der mir das Bild von Monopoly man geschickt hat. Ja, vielen Dank dafür. Also Bilder werden immer gerne gesehen und natürlich, also wenn wir jetzt gerade dabei sind, ich weiß nicht, wo du jetzt genau hin willst mit dieser ganzen Geschichte. Ich auch nicht. Natürlich auch immer die brillanten Bilder von der mit dem Schwanz weht.
Fantastisches Bild, die fantastische Fotomontage, wie ich der einsamen Mutter gewunken habe.
Ganz fantastisch. Vielen Dank dafür.
Basti Fitz hat uns auch mit einem tollen Zitatbild beglückt.
Vielen Dank, ihr seid die beste Community, die man sich überhaupt nur vorstellen kann.
Und ihr seid fantastisch. Das Podcast-Ufo ist eine Bewegung. Und für euch singen wir jetzt I'll Be There For You von The Rembrandts. I'm the one who wants to be with you. Deep inside I hope you feel it too. Dankesch the lines of greens and blues. Ich bin gespannt, wir freuen uns darauf. Das war Folge 23.30 und wir sprechen uns in der nächsten Woche wieder. Bis dahin, wir heben ab. Tschüss!